[Music]
this was the most extraordinary series
of attacks and those responsible remain
on the Run
this is a very rural part of Canada and
over a wide area now police resources
are stretched as they look for two
suspects
Damien Sanderson on the left is 31 and
Miles Sanderson is 30. the police have
not said if the two are related they
have said that they have access to a
vehicle possibly a Nissan and with a
local number plate
they're considered to be dangerous and
should not be approached it was before
Dawn at about 5 30 when the police
received the first 9-1-1 call the
unfolding horror was soon clear with
multiple calls from multiple locations
over a wide area we have located 10
deceased individuals in 13 locations in
the community of of James Smith Cree
Nation and weld in Saskatchewan
several additional victims have been
injured 15 of which at this point have
been transported to various hospitals
there may be additional injured victims
who transported themselves to various
hospitals
the province of Saskatchewan lies in the
center of Canada the community is
targeted a small and isolated from each
other
there appear to have been multiple
stabbings at several locations in James
Smith cremation and the smaller Village
of Weldon half an hour's drive to the
West we're used to seeing stories like
this come out of places like New York or
Los Angeles for us to see the you know
10 deaths to disturbing in such small
communities is
unheard of a James Smith cremation is a
community of nearly 2
000 people Weldon which is nearby has
only 200 people we simply aren't used to
seeing violence like this and Community
is about size so it's very shocking for
a lot of people in a statement the Prime
Minister Justin Trudeau said the attacks
in Saskatchewan today are horrific and
heartbreaking I'm thinking of those who
have lost a loved one and those who are
injured we're closely monitoring the
situation and urge everybody to follow
updates from the local authorities thank
you to all the brave First Responders
for their efforts on the ground
police have suggested that some victims
appear to have been specifically
targeted but they do not yet have a
motive a clear understanding of how or
why this happened Mark Stone Sky News